[Music]
pastor mark the question we have here is
what activities should we avoid on the
sabbath day matt the most important
thing to understand about the sabbath is
what not what we shouldn't do but what
we should do and so here in hebrew the
10th chapter in the 25th verse the bible
says forsaking not yourselves to
assembling together so the bible urges
us
to
meet together to worship together on the
sabbath in fact in leviticus 23 the
bible talks about the sabbath as a holy
convocation the word convocation is
gathering so sabbath is a day to worship
to praise god
it's a day also to rest from our labors
the commandment specifically says that
in exodus 20 remember the sabbath day to
keep it holy six days shalt the labor
and do all thy work but the seventh day
is the sabbath the lord thy god so the
the sabbath is a day for worship it's a
day for rest it's a day for recreation
it's a relaxation it's a day to be with
our families when i use the word
recreation i mean to recreate our bodies
so hiking is perfectly appropriate on
the sabbath after worship at times my
wife and i love to go out and hiking
getting together with friends
now
there's a bible verse that talks about
not doing your own pleasure on the
sabbath that's exactly where i'm going
right now what i was thinking about yeah
okay that's isaiah 58 and so in isaiah
the 58th chapter the bible says this it
talks about
and it's interesting it says
um
verse 12 they that shall be of thee
shall build up the old waste places that
is the sabbath has been torn down we
want to build it back up again thou
shalt raise up the foundations of many
generations should be the restorer of
the breach we're the restore the breach
in god's law now notice verse
13 is the key if you turn away your foot
from the sabbath now what does it mean
to turn away your foot from the sabbath
in ancient times in scripture when you
put your foot on a piece of land you
stepped on it signifying ownership so
what this is saying is you do not own
the sabbath god does from doing your
pleasure on my holy day but call the
sabbath a delight so this the sabbath is
not a day where i dream of what i want
to do but i make the sabbath a delight
how do i find it a delight i find it in
three areas one in worshiping with god's
people it's a delight
secondly in being with my family it's a
delight
thirdly in
the activities of hiking and being out
in nature being with others that's a
delight so it's not that the sabbath is
this day of grimness
but it's rather a day in which we absorb
the blessings of god the sabbath is not
a day according to nehemiah 13 for
buying and selling and it's not a day
for shopping uh some people may think
that's a delight most of us think it's
kind of a
day of tension right right but it's it's
not for buying and selling it's to leave
the world out it's it's not a time to
watch the latest sporting event or the
news it's a time for worship it's a time
to concentrate on our families it's a
time to
be rejuvenated body mind and spirit matt
all right pastor mark thank you for that
answer hey everybody matt gray here
media director for hopeless 365. don't
go yet make sure that you subscribe and
click the bell so you get notified of
the next video in this series and i
think you should check out these other
videos over there i think you'll like
those as well see ya